[Music]
closed schools social distancing remote
learning children's lives have been
turned upside down during the pandemic
you get sad you don't want to do
anything anymore
more than 100 countries around the world
have started to inoculate children
against the coronavirus
i wasn't really afraid i was just
stressed out it might help the planet
feel better once everyone has vaccinated
the majority of countries that will
finally allow us to beat kovid
some parents are on the fence about the
job
but for many families vaccination is the
silver lining after months of living
under pandemic stress
[Music]
welcome to your covenant 19 special here
on dw i'm chris coburn berlin the debate
over the coronavirus jab for children is
a hot topic for many countries
for a month now the united states has
been vaccinating children aged 5 and
over still reservations and
misinformation are unsettling parents
dw's enos pole reports from virginia
this vaccination center in norfolk
virginia does everything to make getting
the jab as comfortable as possible for
children in a special waiting area they
can paint pictures and the nurses tell
them that after the shot they're going
to have a superpower
for nearly a month children five years
and older have been able to get
vaccinated here the u.s health agency
strongly recommends the jab for kids yet
one-third of parents are firmly against
it and one-third want to wait and see
for privacy reasons we were not allowed
to film patients inside
seven-year-old gavin and eight-year-old
brenner just got their second shot
for a couple reasons one is we have
their grandparents and
they're a little bit older and we want
to make sure that we don't get them sick
and then two they're both going to
school and we want to make sure that
they do their part not to get their
friends sick
and if they do get sick that they won't
get it as badly as maybe you know they
could have if they didn't have their
shots it's a divisive issue and with a
lot of misinformation about vaccines
circulating not all parents are
convinced
well there are vaccines that have been
around for
decades we know what those side effects
are
we know how they affect kids
and so we know those those are safe
this vaccine came out so quick that i
think with more time
more studies and everything i think it
could potentially be helpful just right
now i don't think it's there's really
been enough time or enough evidence
i think because it's the unknown
they really don't know what's in it but
even though we get a flu shot every year
you know they're just hesitant about
getting one
dr jaberi is responsible for the
vaccination program in norfolk and knows
how to address these concerns
and we let parents know that this has
been studied and certainly over the last
few weeks we have a lot more real-time
data about the safety and efficacy of
these vaccines it's important for people
to make those decisions
based on good information but at the end
of the day we have to respect personal
autonomy as well
the state of virginia also sends
vaccination buses directly to schools to
get the job out to as many kids as
possible
for more let's bring in kassar talat
she's an infectious disease physician
and vaccine scientist at johns hopkins
university welcome back to the program
khalsa we heard in the report that some
parents fear the covet vaccine might
have been put together too hastily is
that the most common reservation towards
the job for kids
that's one of the reservations although
in reality this is a vaccine that has
been in development for years even
before we knew that stars cov2 the virus
that causes covet even existed
um
but i think the the most
common concern i have i hear from um
from parents about vaccinating their
children is that covet isn't a big deal
in children that it isn't usually severe
and so why should they vaccinate their
kids
and
my answer for that is yes most kids do
fine if they get infected with covid but
some kids get really really sick some
kids develop that syndrome called
multi-system inflammatory syndrome that
can lead them and leave them in the
hospital with multiple organ failure
hundreds of children have died in the
united states from covid
children have died from miic children
can get long covered so kovitt can be
very very severe in children even though
it is less likely to be so than in
adults so vaccination
can be crucial here which side effects
of the vaccination among young children
do you observe
luckily because the dose in young
children is lower than it is in um in
older children or in teens or adults
the side effects are pretty mild they um
the most common side effect is pain
at the injection site um there may be
some fatigue maybe headache um the the
rate of fever is actually
less than half of that that we see in
older kids and adults so the vaccines
and is very well tolerated most of these
side effects are gone within a day or
two
now of course experts are very concerned
now about the omicron
variant the who saying it poses a high
risk globally how could this virus
variant affect children's health
well we're still learning a lot about
this virus there's much that we don't
know and so we
but we do know is that it seems to have
spread very very quickly
and
one of the best ways to protect anybody
against this variant is to vaccinate as
many people as possible and that
includes children
which is more important now though
vaccinating adults or children in this
situation
yeah i think
in general adults have more severe
disease from covid and so if you are in
a place where there is limited vaccine i
would vaccinate adults first however i
think that the world really has failed
in many ways to make sure that everybody
has access to vaccines and so we need to
work really hard to make sure that
vaccines are available everywhere so
people don't have to choose who to
vaccinate that everybody who wants a
vaccine can have a dad can have a
vaccine the united states canada and
israel have been starting
vaccinating
children between the ages of 5 and 11.
the eu
watchstar for medication has given their
thumbs up to the vaccine as well what
has been the response
in the united states to these
vaccinations
for the most part they've been fabulous
many parents including me
wanted to get their kids vaccinated in
part to keep them healthy but also to
keep them in school
if kids are vaccinated and the majority
of kids in the school are vaccinated
then the virus is far less likely to be
transmitted in the school kids don't
have to stay home if they get sick they
don't have to
quarantine if somebody else in their
classroom is sick
and so you know i i think most parents
really are excited to
keep their kids healthy keep them in
school and learning and having normal
activities but for some it is a tough
call to make let's say if i have a
four-year-old kid and i'm worried that
she might contract the virus should i
get her vaccinated even if the jab is
only for kids five years or older
no the vaccine currently is only
authorized for children five years and
older we will hopefully have vaccines
for kids under five soon but i would not
get a child who isn't old enough to be
vaccinated vaccinated yet
infectious disease physician and vaccine
scientist at johns hopkins university
thank you for being back here on dw
thank you very much
and speaking about variants people have
been worried about them since the
pandemic began now that is a question
our science correspondent derek williams
tackled back in february
[Music]
as the sars cov2 virus inevitably
continues to mutate could it also mutate
to become less deadly
this is complicated but here goes the
short answer is yes that could happen
and and we hope it will but there's no
guarantee
scientists used to believe that
pathogens always evolved to grow less
deadly because it was thought a deadly
disease is an ineffective disease the
reasoning was
that if a pathogen kills its host
especially if it kills that host quickly
then it lowers its own chances of being
passed on so
less deadly more transmissible variants
should have an evolutionary advantage
right
well the problem with that logic is that
virulence can also be viewed as an
advantage because
the sicker the host grows the more
likely they are
to give their pathogen to someone else
since they're shedding more of it some
so we actually think there's kind of a
an evolutionary trade-off between
transmissibility
and virulence and and there are
certainly pathogens for instance the
tuberculosis bacterium that have been
infecting humans for thousands of years
yet still kill large numbers of people
to see what the future might hold for
covet 19 therefore scientists have been
looking
at the other coronaviruses known to
infect humans in particular the four
that we think have been doing it for
quite a while um they only cause mild
cold-like symptoms interestingly
that might have less to do with them and
more to do with us especially with our
children
one theory is that repeated exposure to
those other coronaviruses and early
childhood
might be helping to prevent
more severe cases of the sicknesses they
could cause later in life if cyrus cove2
does become an endemic background
illness in our societies then then later
generations of children will be exposed
to it early at an age when it rarely
makes you seriously ill and and that in
turn
should make subsequent exposures much
less dangerous or at least that's the
hope
[Music]
you